so donald trump did another rally last
night this one was in pennsylvania where
donald trump is now losing to joe biden
by an
average of seven points and donald trump
actually asked women to like him during
yesterday's rally we will get to that
but let's start in order piece by piece
donald trump kicking off the rally by
slamming joe biden because joe biden
abandoned pennsylvania when he was 10
years old
how do you lose to a guy like this is oh
i'll never come to pennsylvania again i
love this one
you know they say he was born in
scranton but he left
he left he abandoned you he didn't give
me a break
this would be like uh attacking me for
abandoning argentina when i was five
as if at age five i could have said
thanks mom and dad
i'm gonna stick around here instead of
moving to the united states with you a
really
strange line of attack but nothing
matters to these crowds
they will cheer anything this next one i
love
i don't know if you guys have seen but
pete boudage edge or
buddha judge has been on fox news a lot
lately
crushing crushing trump so trump
apparently doesn't like it and he talked
about pete but a judge at yesterday's
rally
except he called him booty check which
is uh different
you had uh alfred newman you had all
these people
you know who alfred e newman is yes pete
budeck
pete budeck he's a bad mayor of a failed
town and he's going to run for president
just uh just wild stuff i mean it's
insane that this is the reality we live
in and then here's that strangest moment
of the entire thing when donald trump
asked suburban women to like him
a sort of uh jeb bush please clap moment
except much more cringy this was after
about 90 seconds of ranting incoherently
i i don't want to build low income
housing next to your house okay if
that's okay
and i ended the regulation the rule that
made the zoning so impossible that you
had to destroy your communities
and then i hear the the suburban woman i
think that the suburban woman
and i used to say suburban housewife i
used to take heat but i said
does anybody care do you care if i say
surprise no they're all going no
again the only one cares is them trump
said suburban house what but i didn't
say it
because i don't you learn very quickly
you learned very quickly
but suburban women they should like me
more than anybody here tonight
because i ended the regulation
that destroyed your neighborhood i ended
the regulation that brought crime to the
suburbs
and you're going to live the american
dream and that's what you're going to do
and remember this 29
of the people experiencing the american
dream in the suburbs happen to be
minority and you don't know that but 29
and we're doing this for everybody we're
not doing it one way or the other we're
doing it
and i ended it they said sir we can
amend it i said i don't want to amend it
i want to end it it was a horror show
and this loser corey booker
is the guy that's going to be in charge
of the program the guy's a stone called
loser
one percent he got one percent he ran he
was going gonna be great you know one
percent
every week he was like her down down
down they should have picked him
but no he'll be in charge of your uh
suburban so can
i ask you to do me a favor suburban
women will you please like me
is that a message of hope and change or
what right suburban women
please like me that you may want to
workshop that messaging to women a
little bit it could probably you you
might want to focus group that a little
bit before you
you commit to women please like me then
donald trump again pulling out this line
that he's now immune to reinfection from
coronavirus
and wants to kiss all the men and women
in the audience
let's take a look at this next clip and
now i'm immune they tell me i'm immune i
could come down and start kissing
everybody
i'll kiss every guy man and woman man
and woman look at that guy how handsome
he is
i'll kiss him not not with a lot of
enjoyment but that's okay
joe biden would terminate our recovery
delay the vaccine
one of the funniest things about donald
trump's rallies
is you can tell from his tone
when he's kind of riffing and when he's
on the teleprompter
and sometimes the contrast is so stark
when he goes from riffing back to the
prompter
which by the way he did it there he he
slams biden all the time for using a
teleprompter trump using one as well
it's almost jarring when trump gets back
on the prompter because it's like two
different speeches
woven together in a bizarre amalgam of
insanity
trump then asked the crowd how many of
you have had coronavirus
now this is funny for a few reasons
first of all he congratulates them for
being immune which as you all know there
are still questions about reinfection
how long immunity lasts etc
not particularly responsible for for
trump to go head first on this
but you know when you have people
crowded together during a pandemic
asking the infected folks even if it's
previous i mean who really knows when
when they last
had it or would have tested positive
asking people to raise their hands to
say i had coronavirus
you're not going to get a lot of takers
i don't think but regardless trump tries
it take a look
i'm hard the fda has been great to
everyone fighting to recover from the
virus
i feel your pain because i felt your
pain
and we will beat this virus together
and for those who has had it who has had
it here who's had it
yeah a lot of people a lot of people
you're the people i want to say hello to
because you are right now
immune you're right now immune or they
say that you know they hate to admit it
because i had it
not how i would try to get a crowd fired
up by having those masked
together who have had coronavirus put
their hands up and say yeah i had it not
not
exactly making people feel too good and
then donald trump
wrapping up with this pre-packaged piece
of his stump speech that he's been using
a lot now
and the crowd just loves it nation under
god
and together with the incredible people
of pennsylvania
we have made america wealthy again
we have made america strong again
we have made america proud again
and we will make america safe again
and we will make america great again
thank you very much pennsylvania thank
you get out and vote
vote vote vote completely and utterly
surreal events we hopefully are down to
the last three weeks of trump rallies
we will ever have and then done so if we
vote if we
if we get it done uh tonight 7 p.m
eastern trump will be in
iowa i will be live on youtube twitch
and facebook
i hope you'll join me for audience
participation and live commentary
if not i understand i i really do and
hopefully we're down to the last three
weeks of this
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company
best known for their delicious mushroom
coffee
four sigmatics mushroom coffee is
organic
fair trade single origin arabica coffee
with both lion's mane and chaga
mushrooms chaga mushrooms have actually
been shown to have potential in
supporting the immune system
in peer-reviewed studies i've been
drinking four
sigmatic coffee a lot lately it actually
doesn't taste anything like mushrooms it
just tastes like any
delicious coffee but it's really easy on
my stomach doesn't give me any jittery
feeling or a midday crash
and they have over 20 thousand five star
reviews and best of all if you don't
love it
you'll get 100 percent of your money
back because
they stand behind their product you've
got nothing to lose by giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to 40 percent off
and free shipping when you go to
4sigmatic.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video